each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
our project is working on data-intensive
applications and from Indiana University
we have a group of cs students and staff
and this project is supervised by dr.
Fox and we work with Microsoft and also
domain experts from different areas here
is the chart of data intensive
architecture at the bottom stack is the
bare metal hits computers networking and
storage on top of that is a future grid
platform future queries the new new
leaves and it's funded project providing
testbed for supporting new approaches to
parallel grids and the cloud computing
for science applications and on top of
that we develop a cloud Tecna using
technologies like mapreduce dryad and
Hadoop and also have systems like
classic 8pc including MP and it's ready
and we develop a suite of data mining
algorithms including kasturi and
multidimensional scaling general
topographic mapping and principal
component analysis and correlated
canonical correlation analysis and also
we develop our own visualization tools
and on the top of the stack is a suite
of applications our focus is on
biomedical and there are two about
application one is assembly of genes
another is the gym pair of sequence
alignment and health the application
will try to correlate a childhood
obesity to environmentally in meta data
and the pack comdata would try to reduce
the dimension from high dimension to low
dimension to aid drug discovery and our
work is based on the top three stacks
and winter fizzy future with and with to
work with them to test our applications
here I borrow the architecture from
futuregrid and we have with windows and
the linux cluster to test our
applications and this is the details we
have a 256 course of linux cluster and
new layer tempest windows car service
768 cause
we have a view of cloud computing i has
two components one is the infrastructure
another is the runtime the youth
destruction including that dynamic
providing of services through the
virtual machines and the runtimes
including what I mentioned in the
previous slides including though there
are clouds runtimes of MapReduce are
hadoo band dryad and what we're trying
to find out is that if this kind of very
successful you from a mission of trivial
technology can be extended to use on
scientific applications like we care
about and I will elaborate a little bit
about our approach and give a conclusion
at the end and the main issue is that
are complicated applications in data
mining use the iterative MapReduce and
we try to find out how to work this out
here's another chart of a data intensive
architecture so we have a bunch of data
from the sensors and from the web and
they're very large in in volume and
initially they go to sieve into database
or files and I got the initial
processing to reduce the data size and
this is a pipeline and filters this is
iterative and we have the different
stages we can apply all sorts of our
algorithms or data mining tools and at
the end we have the result and put into
a visualization this chart is a detailed
chart for MapReduce structure we have a
map and which is a data parallel
computation and in the in between those
different maps we have a communication
through messages and files and the
important step is reduced to combine all
the result and we finally as provide the
results to users through the portals
interface while we have a lot of
implementation of data mining algorithms
I give a simple example of our lower
sequencing and a low is one of the
largest gene families in human genome oh
and it's important because you have over
1 million gene sequences and we have
this this problem is that we have a
jeans and Eugene's have to pair with the
other genes to calculate distance and
this is the N squared problems so first
we need to calculate the distance matrix
and then we try to use this district
meet restore the classroom
gene families and then we reduce the
high dimension to lower like three
dimension and then we visualize them
notice that we have tested around 50,000
jeans and this problem will runs total
10 hours are now 768 cause here's the
chart of our workflow first we calculate
the on the distance matrix and this is a
block scattered algorithm just twisted a
little bit you've seen that because
symmetry and we only call calculated the
upper top of the distance and then we
used to Draya will try to use the blog
assigned to notes and I do the map step
and it fighting the files and then
combine the results and we notice that
there is a processes in working better
in using threats and the Dryad we
implementing dryad and the MPI and there
have a comparable performance notice
that a total gene distance calculation
is a 1215 millions and this takes like
less than five hours on the clusters
this is a detailed chart of this
algorithm and I give some snapshot of
our result and this is the aloe sequency
and if you can see that this is a big
mess in red color this is the old gene
families and the younger ones evolved
which is smaller and it's the yellow and
green colors this is another application
as well metagenomics and I try to use
this snapshot to show that genes
families has very distinct clusters and
structures this is the interesting to
biologists because you can see that it
clearly the custard through different
colors and we have extensive performance
testing on all our algorithms this is
for pairwise algorithms would try to use
this chart to show that deep in the
parallel strategy and thread versus mpi
when the lower parel isms like NPR works
very well and the 16 will parallelism
that threat and MPI equivalent and when
the parallelism going up to 744 then the
NPI doesn't work very well this is a
common in classic parallel computing
because the communication takes a lot of
times this chart
to our show that the scaling of the
system and when this flat shows the
system scale well on the y-axis shows
the time / distance calculation and we
have tested on different number of
sequences and we can show that roughly
flat so this isn't working very well
another scaling test is not over the
number of three sequences but over the
calls we can get this similar will
behave to behave the systems and this
chart will try to study the difference
in homogeneous of data impact on all
systems and we find that we create gene
lenses and the average is 400 but we
have the descender deviation from 0 up
to 300 if you see that on to up to 300
extreme case that performed quite well
there's another compression of the tooth
cloud technology Hadoop versus dryad
using homogeneous data this is a this ad
run on different pieces on the one is on
linux and another one is on Windows and
they have a comparable result and this
chart shows that the homogeneous data as
you expected because the data
distribution is quite similar they
should have similar result we try to
emphasize that there are a lot of
complication in the system including the
cash effect we tested that that cache
size when is too big and which is the
block size is smaller and each block has
too much too many g data they were not
fit in the cache in the system will not
perform as well there's another ballot
the application we have his capture is
the genes Embling just similar to our
the previous speakers talk and we have a
simple map and reduced step of in this
application there's a date of parallel
and we try to show that in our testing
we have a three cloud or equivalent
technologies one is a loop and dry out
on an all streamed technology not
directly to file system they have a
comparable result we also test our
system in cloud commercial cloud
services and you using go grid and this
isn't
32 nose virtual cluster and we tested on
bare metal and verses on the virtual
machines a bare metal it's a three times
better and this is not apple the Apple
compression because we cannot have the
details of the settings on their virtual
commercial virtual environment but we
expect they will be better if we were
working on the futuregrid because all
the systems that are we in control we
can install windows within linux and the
virtual machine bare metal we can come
compare all of them in the same systems
and hear some result of comparing that
is a k-means clustering algorithms and
we try to show on the right hand side
that if the granularity of the size is
going up there is a penalty of virtual
machine overhead and there's three times
worse here I summarize the applications
as suitable for cloud technology like
mapreduce and we have classified the
application into a synchro nears like
simdi model and the loosely synchronous
and mostly MPI jobs and actually I
synchronous or not use that much and a
priest in peril is a 20-percent erode
classic HPC applications but now we
expect new application is more racial
and this is super for grid systems and
the major problem is large kanya larity
like workflow type and we also
introduced the MapReduce Eclipse plus
plaus is our own development of map
technology using streaming and in this
we can use the this chart to summarize
that what is the MapReduce pattern and
we have a simple pattern is the input
and map and route put this shoulder in
our cap three example if I explained
before and we have also some classic
ones is that input map and then have an
important to reduce step this we have a
smith-waterman gene alignment example
and more our company kills one algorithm
or use a iterative MapReduce and this is
a very important class a class and then
on the right-hand side we compare the
MPI patterns so we have algorithms
implemented determination leaning
clustering
the MDS and this all fit into this
category to end my talk I have
summarized the features of approach and
we believe that cloud technologies work
very well for data-intensive
applications and the iterative mapreduce
allows to build a complete system of
single cloud technology without using
MPI and we believe that futuregrid will
provide an important testing bed for us
to testify with all this kind of data
intensive science applications
especially using virtual machines and
this is a work we're focusing on right
now and will provide some results and
live demo in supercomputing finally this
is the project website www informal talk
salsa and we'll have some moss or some
presentation and I you both in
supercomputing for futuregrid thank you
thank you very much for your patience
any questions
the catheter a 10k and the k-means is
four million no
yes sometimes because of the cash in
fact we have a super linear speed-up
this is very common we have never tested
that net direction
thank you
you